Hello to all the marvel fans in China i'm Kevin
Feige president of marvel studios 2020 has been an
unusual year for all of us but together we've kept
hope alive in the face of unprecedented challenges
and we've never stopped telling the tales of
heroes next year marvel studios will continue
to bring inspiring stories to the big screen
including black widow shang chi and the legend
of the ten rings as well as eternals welcoming
a brand new era in the marvel cinematic universe
before that there will also be a marvel themed
musical performance to welcome the new year tune
in to the billy billy new year's gala on december
31st and get a glimpse of what's to come in 2021
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new marvel phase 4 video kevin feige
hyping up their big new year's celebration and
some trailers that they're going to be dropping
on new year's eve there's also a bunch of big
new spider-man 3 stuff happening that i'll talk
about during the video too if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all those
videos of course i'll be doing easter egg videos
for anything that they wind up releasing if you
have no idea what's going on though kevin feige
just announced on china's major social networking
sites through their marvel accounts that marvel
is doing a special new year's eve celebration with
marvel themed musical performances and as part of
that they're running marvel phase 4 trailers for
the movies and their upcoming projects like he
says he hypes up mostly the movies i say they'd
also include new footage for the disney plus
projects like loki falcon and winter soldier
wandavision hawkeye episodes maybe but here's the
thing china does not have disney plus and they're
probably not going to get it anytime soon there's
some countries around the world where disney has
to operate through other companies inside those
countries just because of weird trade business
rules really good example of that is a country
like india they get all the disney plus shows just
like everyone else like star wars the mandalorian
all the marvel stuff that's coming up but disney
releases it through another streaming company that
they bought inside that country called hotstar so
that's probably why as part of this big china
bilili festival for new year's eve kevin
feige is mostly hyping up the marvel phase four
movies black widow being the first one that's
still coming out in may shang chi the legend
of the ten rings i've actually been pronouncing
it shang chi maybe shang shi is the more correct
pronunciation of that movie if we're talking about
2021 that's coming out this summer even though
technically there are a couple days left in 2020
as of me posting this video and then obviously
marble eternals movie coming out in november
and obviously there's a pretty big spider-man
movie spider-man 3 coming out in december but
being that this is an asian festival in an asian
country marvel is making its first asian martial
arts themed movie there's a pretty solid chance
that at this event we'll get our first actual look
at the shang chi footage i've already done a couple
videos for the shane chief footage we have seen
so far in the larger iron man easter eggs going
into marvel phase four they were filming the
movie when the virus first hit way back in march
even though that seems like a lifetime ago now
one of the cooler iron man connections
is obviously the real mandarin of the mcu
in a sort of continuation of that teaser from
the iron man 3 one shot all hail the king in
the seagate prison with trevor and justin hammer
a couple of the new marvel phase 4 disney plus
shows that they announced at the disney investor
meeting are iron man themed shows like armor wars
with war machine so i know a lot of you are also
hoping for justin hammer to come back for that
but this is the actor who's playing the actual
real mcu mandarin for those of you that aren't
super familiar with the shang chi character or
maybe didn't read the classic comics i think
i've mentioned this in a couple of my previous
videos but when they created the character in the
1970s it was part of this big pop culture kung
fu craze and bruce lee was blowing up with his
movies at the time so marvel obviously wanted to
get in on that so they made themselves a version
of bruce lee in the marvel universe and called
him shang chi bringing things full circle now the
shang chi movie is actually doing basically the
tournament arc of enter the dragon so it's like
marvel's remake of enter the dragon except this
time there's an actual dragon in the movie in
the shang chi and the legend of the 10 rings movie
marvel is just combining some of the bigger asian
themed characters and easter eggs from different
iron man titles and we get a very big marvel
dragon from the classic comics the funny thing
about fing fang fun though is that he's not an
actual dragon in the traditional sense like a game
of thrones dragon or a wyvern he's actually an
alien that just looks like a dragon his race are
called the maculens the other big iron man easter
egg for his character is that his race are the
ones that created the mandarins ten rings of power
the mandarin obtained them thousands of years ago
at least in the comics when he stumbled upon their
spaceship which had crashed in the mountains where
he lived kevin feige also implied that they might
be showing off some footage for the eternals
movie that could just be the same footage that
they showed off back at brazil comic con ccxp
in december last year that's how long it's been
i did a video for that footage a long long time
ago so i'll put a link for that in the description
for those of you asking why we don't see
kid harrington's black knight character
in any of the newer eternals previews
and teasers that they've been releasing
that's just because they don't want to confuse
people about what's going on with the characters
the black knight's real name is dane whitman his
family descends from the original black knight
of the king arthur mythology kit harrington's
character is just the latest member of their
family who inherits the title when he inherits
the ebony blade that's really what's passed down
in their family with the title their ancestral
sword that's cursed but also gives him crazy power
the sword gives him a lot of storm breaker level
powers and abilities like as long as he's touching
any part of the blade he can't be killed no matter
how much damage he soaks and the blade allows him
to teleport he's also got some crazy black armor
that they referenced during spider-man far from
home when they go into the tower of london to hide
from the iron man star tech drones they're running
through the museum exhibit one of the suits of
armor belonged to the black knight's ancestor
so he's not an eternal like the other characters
or a deviant there were a lot of marvel phase 4
movie teasers and easter eggs in that movie the
biggest one aside from spider-man 3 and obviously
this new eternals preview is probably the new
version of fantastic four in that ending scene
right before the post credits because obviously
now we know that john watts the director of all
the mcu spider-man films and now spider-man 3
will be the new director of the mcu fantastic
four movies i know everyone's got all kinds
of questions and theories about what's going
on with mcu fantastic four i will do a video for
the teaser that they released for that pretty soon
because now we actually know a little bit about
what's going on with the movie and there are some
other fantastic four easter eggs in the new marvel
phase four projects like the loki series all those
loki episodes are going to start dropping in may
so we won't have to wait that long to actually
find out what this new version of fantastic four
is going to look like but looking forward to
avengers 5 the other really cool thing about the
new avengers roster is that when they eventually
get to that movie sort of bringing this back
around to eternals is that kevin feige implied
kit harrington was going to join the team he did
this interview after they announced kit harrington
was joining the marvel movies that was right after
game of thrones season 8 finale and everyone was
wondering what kid harrington was going to do
next after spending 10 plus years of his life
on that show this is what kevin feige said about
his character beyond the eternals movie in future
marvel movies he's a really amazing actor and this
part came up in the eternals film that we're doing
we were so happy when he agreed to join and it is
a part that could perhaps grow into something else
in the future the something more he's referencing
is obviously the black knight and cersei of the
eternals eventually joining the avengers in
the comics because they did become full-blown
avengers for a while also kind of funny that
his romantic interest in the eternals movie is
also named cersei after doing game of thrones
with lena headey's cersei lannister i'm sure
when they start releasing those marvel eternals
trailers the memes are going to be off the charts
next time i see you you'll be dressed all in black
and so he was richard madden is playing icarus in
the movie he's one of the main characters it's an
ensemble film with a bunch of characters but he's
one of the more major characters then of course
there's all the spider-man 3 sony promised some
sort of spider-man 3 teaser before the end of 2020
and we're closing down like as i'm posting this
video we only got a couple days left in the year
thankfully only a couple days left we'll be able
to say goodbye to this crap year we've been having
pretty soon i don't know if sony still plans on
releasing any kind of spider-man 3 footage it
was a sony producer working on the spider-man
movies who said that earlier this year but it
was a while ago and the reason why you didn't
see spider-man 3 during the big marvel phase 4
panel is mostly because that was disney hyping up
disney plus and all their streaming stuff and when
it comes to all the live-action spider-man stuff
with tom hall like spider-man 3 sony usually
handles a lot of the marketing plans on that
so they decide when they release the trailers not
marvel there are so many rumors about multiverse
spider-verse easter eggs going on in spider-man 3
alternate spider-man versions you all know about
the andrew garfield tobey maguire stuff right now
the report is that they're still trying to close
tobey maguire's contract and once that deal is
in place then they'll start promoting the movie
more in releasing teasers the other new latest
rumor about alternate versions of spider-man is
leonardo dicaprio and if it sounds weird that
he cameo is an alternate universe version of
spider-man if you don't remember way way back
the reason why that would be kind of a big deal
is because he almost became spider-man before the
tobey maguire era of spider-man movies he would
have been james cameron spider-man back in the 90s
when he was trying to make a version of that movie
but all this big multiverse stuff is gonna start
during the one division episodes that's gonna be
january 15th for episode one there are some actual
prequel episodes some bonus content that marvel
is releasing the week before that called marvel
legends so i'll do some episode videos for that
too that'll be january 8th there is a bonus
episode of the mandalorian that's supposed to
drop christmas day this week obviously there's
a bunch of other big stuff happening so as long
as you have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see all those videos when i post them
but everyone click here for my full star wars
mandalorian season 2 episode 8 finale video in
all my bonus videos and click here to learn about
what's going on with spider-man 3 tobey maguire
and andrew garfield thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!